letzte woche fand in las vegas die
consumer electronics show und neben 94
fern werden und martin kühl schränken
war ein trend ganz klar selbst fahrende
autos ford bmw mercedes rover und nvidia
arbeiten alle gerade an autos die uns in
zukunft selbständig durch die straßen
kurven wollen
aber wie funktioniert das eigentlich
genau wie kann ein computer lernen auto
zu fahren
[Musik]
hey leute zuallererst frohes neues jahr
2000 sitze ich hoffe dass alle eine
schöne und vor allem ruhige zeit mit
euren familien und seit gut ins neue
jahr gekommen
wir starten ins neue jahr direkt mit
einer großen aktion zum thema künstliche
fliegen
ein paar meiner liebsten youtuber in
dieser szene hier 46 beibringt und
lesben haben alle spannende videos zum
thema gemacht und wir sondern alle diese
videos in einer großen playlist bei mir
geht es um selbstfahrende autos brennen
darauf ein thema das ich selber mega
spannend finde und eigentlich beinahe
täglich verfolge denn es kann wirklich
unheimlich sein
wie kann ein computer eine alte
rechenmaschine so gut sein dass sie
etwas so komplex ist wieder fahren eines
autos vollbringen kann
fangen wir mal mit den basics an dem wir
so wie sie da menschliche autofahrer auf
die straße gucken muss um zu fahren muss
auch ein selbst fahrendes auto seiner
umgebung genau beobachten
dafür hat es eine reihe von
verschiedenen sensoren die alle
unterschiedliche aufgabenbereiche
abdecken können
die meisten selbstfahrenden autos haben
zum beispiel auf ihrem dach einen
sogenannten light sensor das ist
vereinfacht ein sich drehender laser der
in alle richtungen kurze sicht impulse
schickt und darauf warten wie lange es
dauert bis das licht von der umgebung
wieder zurück reflektiert wurde
je länger das dauert desto weiter ist
dieses objekt vom auto entfernt
auf diese weise entsteht eine
dreidimensionale karte der umgebung die
mehrere male in der sekunde geupdatet
wird diese daten werden dann durch
andere sensoren erweitert wie zum
beispiel radargeräte die zwar nur in
jeweils eine richtung blicken können
dafür aber viel größere distanzen
abdecken
ganz wichtig sind auch kamera die dinge
wie zum beispiel straßen schilder und
ampeln lesen können all diese daten
werden dann an einem ort gesammelt und
mit gps-daten zusammengesetzt je nach
hersteller wird auch auf kartenmaterial
zurückgegriffen da vorher aufgenommen
wurde
nun folgt der zweite schritt der
computer beginnt die daten zu
interpretieren was ist ein auto und was
ein fahrradfahrer verdacht auf eine rote
oder eine grüne ampel an dieser stelle
wird machine learning eingesetzt um die
aufgabe zu erleichtern
denn eine dreidimensionale punkte wolke
eines autos wird auf jeder perspektive
und für jedes modell anders aus das auto
muss lernen welche aspekte einer solchen
punkte wolke auf ein typisches auto
schießen lassen und welche er ein
fahrrad oder einen lkw vermuten lassen
will hat zu diesem thema ein ganzes
video erstellt das könnt euch hier oben
ansehen
aber die kurze version ist das dem
algorithmus millionen und abermillionen
von autos und fahrrädern gezeigt wurden
und dieser dadurch lernen konnte was
alle exemplare einer kategorie gemeinsam
haben und was nicht okay wenn das auch
jetzt nicht nur seine umwelt sieht
sondern auch versteht kann es die
wichtigen entscheidungen treffen und das
sind im endeffekt mit zwei parameter
gebe ich gas oder bremse und lenkrad
nach links oder rechts mehr brauchte vom
autofahren nicht um diese entscheidung
zu treffen muss das auto aber natürlich
viele faktoren mit einbeziehen wie
schnell fahre ist was ist die
höchstgeschwindigkeit hier wie viel
abstand habe ich von auto vor mir und
nicht mehr schwer dieses auto und wird
der fahrradfahrer neben ihr beim
abbiegen weil es weit nach vorne eine
baustelle und auch bei diesen
entscheidungen schlicht künstliche
intelligenz eine wichtige rolle denn das
auto lernt wie ein mensch auf den
bereits gefahrenen kilometern und das
nicht nur von sich selber sondern auch
von allen anderen selbstfahrenden autos
der firma auf diese weise können relativ
schnell millionen von kilometern fahrer
erfahrungen gesammelt werden und es ist
wichtig dass das möglich schnell
passiert denn jedes jahr sterben auf den
straßen dieser erde 1,2 millionen
menschen an autounfällen über 90 prozent
davon durch menschliche fehler und es
muss nicht einmal wie das auto
selbstständig fahren um diese zahl zu
verringern
dieses video auf den niederlanden gegen
vor ein paar tagen durch ein fenster
auto war eine fahrerin auf der autobahn
bevor der crash passiert
das war durch die radarsensoren des
autos möglich wie auch um ecken und
somit zwei autos nach vorne schauen
können der tester war das ein unfall
unvermeidbar und bremst den wagen ab um
einen auffahrunfall zu verhindern
fürs erste häufig solche sehen die
autonomen auto für die sinnvollste
lösung der mensch fährt selber oder kann
auf klar markierten strecken das steuer
abgeben aber zu jeder zeit ins geschehen
eingreifen
wenn dann etwas passiert dass der fahrer
nicht vorhersehen kann reagiert das auto
und bringt den wagen in sicherheit
ich bin mega gespannt nicht in dieser
thematik weiter geht und ab wann wir die
ersten komplett selbst fahrenden autos
kaufen können bis dahin könnt euch die
anderen südafrika in der playlist
anschauen angefangen mit dem ersten
video von rising fliegens ist künftig im
fliegen tief was dabei uns bis zum
nächsten mal
heuer fertig
[Musik]